if you're interested in learning Turkish
check out Turkish uncovered an excellent
course which takes you from a beginner
level all the way up to intermediate
click the link in the description to
check it out
back in 2016 I released my first video
on the Turkish language millions of
people have seen it but unfortunately it
kind of sucked I didn't explain very
much about the language and the
production quality was a bit hokey so
it's time for a reboot the Turkish
language is the language of turkey or
turkey as it's now officially known an
incredibly important country at the
crossroads of Europe and Western Asia
because turkey lies at the edge of the
Middle East and borders Syria and Iraq
people who don't know much about the
world often assume that the language of
turkey must be Arabic but that's not the
case Turkish belongs to a completely
separate language family the turkic
language family the turkic language
family has over 170 million native
speakers stretching all the way from
Europe to Northeast Asia the speakers of
turkic languages often consider all of
them to be dialects of one language but
it's better to consider them closely
related sister languages when I talk
about Turkish in this video I'm talking
about the Turkish language of Turkey
edit standardized variety based on the
dialect of Istanbul there are around 90
million native speakers of Turkish
mainly in Turkey but also in Northern
Cyprus and other neighboring areas
some linguists have theorized that the
turkic languages are part of a larger
language family called altaic which
includes the mongolic and tungusic
languages and even corianic and japonic
Languages by some definitions this
theoretic family is named after the
altai mountains of Central Asia but the
existence of the altaic language family
is highly disputed it's more commonly
thought that the similarities between
the languages in this group come from
contact rather than a common origin but
the common ancestor language of all the
turkic languages proto-turkic probably
originated in or near Mongolia around
the 6th Century the first known turkic
inscriptions known as the orcorn
inscriptions date back to this time
turkic speakers migrated over a wide
area stretching from Siberia through
China and Central Asia through Western
Asia and up into the Balkans and the
North Black Sea region OS turkic the
ancestor language of today's Turkish
language and the entire OS Branch was
brought to Anatolia by a turkic Empire
known as the seljuk empire in the 11th
century because the seljuk empire were
admirers of Persian culture and were
Muslims their language was influenced by
the Persian and Arabic languages turkic
was spoken by Everyday People while
Persians served as the administrative
and literary language and Arabic served
as the language of religion when the
Ottoman Empire arose after the decline
and breakup of the seljuk Empire a form
of Turkish which was highly influenced
by Persian and Arabic became the
official language and literary language
this was Ottoman Turkish
ottoman Turkish contained a very large
number of Persian and Arabic loanwords
According to some estimates it was over
80 percent though that depends on how
you calculate it and on the context this
was the language of the elite and wasn't
the same as the everyday Turkish
language used by Regular People which
had less foreign influence but still had
some during the time of Ottoman rule
French was the main language of
international diplomacy and there were
close relations between the Ottomans and
the French for much of the time the
influence of France led to the adoption
of numerous French lawn words into
Turkish when the Republic of Turkey was
founded in 1923 its first president
Mustafa kimal Ataturk initiated a
language reform and got rid of Ottoman
Turkish he created a new standard
language based on the everyday spoken
dialect of Istanbul an effort was made
to replace Persian and Arabic words with
Turkish equivalents and the Arabic
script was replaced with a modified
Latin script which would be more
suitable for the Turkish language
official language reforms are usually
not completely successful so there are
still a lot of loan words in modern
Turkish just not as many as there were
in ottoman Turkish according to the
Turkish language Association 12 percent
of the words in Turkish are loan words
though it could be higher depending on
how you calculate them we'll look at
some examples of loan words in Turkish
in a minute but first a few words about
a Turkish course I think you should
check out if you're excited to learn
Turkish I highly recommend you check out
the course Turkish uncovered by the
company's story learning Turkish
uncovered was created by Ollie Richards
a major figure in the language learning
community whose approach to language
learning is based on using stories you
may have seen some of his best-selling
books at your local bookstore or on
Amazon including his book on Turkish his
uncovered courses are based on the same
philosophy of story learning but they're
much more extensive and are designed to
take you from a beginner level up to the
B1 level which is lower intermediate so
that you can genuinely communicate at a
basic level with Turkish people the
course consists of 20 chapters of a
story with each chapter containing not
only a core reading and listening lesson
but also additional video lessons and
exercises that build on that core
material
if you're tired of boring apps and
grammar-based translation I recommend
you try the story learning approach with
Turkish uncovered if you use my link in
the description you can try it for seven
days for free and if you upgrade to a
paid course langfocus gets a small
commission that helps support this
channel so it's win-win it's great for
you and it's great for langfocus by the
way Turkish isn't the only language in
the uncovered series they have courses
for Spanish French German and other
languages I'll put a link to this page
with all of their courses in the
description below and now back to the
main video let's see some examples of
foreign loan words that are still widely
used in modern Turkish some words from
Arabic meaning book from Arabic
meaning coffee from Arabic
meaning history from Arabic
pen or pencil from Arabic
meaning letter from Arabic Mac tube
Ada meaning gift from Arabic hadiya
salt meaning our or a specific time from
Arabic SA
meaning time in a general sense from
Arabic zemen
Persian loan words meaning market and
also Sunday because Sunday is the market
day from Persian Bazaar Ze meaning
vegetable from Persian sabzi maybe
meaning fruit from Persian mewa
meaning Garden from Persian meaning a
small garden
meaning color from Persian dang
meaning each or every from Persian had
hard case meaning everyone from Persian
had a case
some French long words office meeting
office from French Office television
meaning television from French
television music meaning music from
French music
meaning hotel from French Hotel
meaning trained from French huh
meaning pants from French
meaning newspaper from French Gazette
meaning a periodical with government
notices
meaning reservation from French
reservation
now let's look at some more features of
Turkish Turkish is an agglutinative
language meaning words are formed by
adding suffixes to a root in a linear
manner each suffix has a single
grammatical or semantic function and
long strings of multiple suffixes can be
added for example let's see the
possessive suffixes that are attached to
nouns let's start with the word meaning
House eh
your house with your in the plural or
formal singular his her or its house
their house but more suffixes can be
added let's make the noun plural so it
means houses
is the suffix that makes the noun plural
My houses
our houses it is in your houses with
your in the singular is your houses with
your in the plural or formal singular
his her or its houses
their houses notice that it can mean his
her or its houses their house or their
houses lies can indicate the plural of
either the noun or the possessor
creating ambiguity
Standalone possessive pronouns can be
used together with the possessive suffix
to give emphasis or clarity as in this
case
his houses
their house
their houses
now let's go back to just the root word
and one suffix
houses here's another example
some heads note the difference in the
suffixes added to the two notes it's a
result of something called vowel Harmony
vowel Harmony affects suffixes that are
added to the noun so before we look more
closely at Turkish agglutination let's
take a look at vowel Harmony and some
other related features
vowel Harmony means that the vowels in a
Turkish word must be in harmony with
each other they must share certain
features specifically backness and
roundness and because words in Turkish
are built by adding suffixes the vowels
of a suffix change depending on the
vowels in the word it's being attached
to there are two sets of vowels
depending on backness front vowels and
back vowels each word normally only has
vowels from one of those categories so
when a suffix is added to a word the
vowel in the suffix must match the
category of the last vowel that appears
before the suffix there are two types of
vowel Harmony depending on the possible
vowels that can appear in a particular
suffix E-Type vowel Harmony
meaning cat kitty lies meaning cats odds
meaning Tree Art slash trees these two
words have the same plural suffix but
the vowel is different similar to the
pair of words we saw before the vowel ah
in the suffix large is a back vowel in
order to be in harmony with the back
vowels in the root word and the vowel e
in the suffix is a front vowel to be in
harmony with the front vowels in the
root word
when the vowel in a particular suffix
varies between e and a front and back
it's called E-Type vowel Harmony there's
also I type vowel Harmony in i-type
vowel Harmony the vowel in the suffix
has one of four variations it harmonizes
with the preceding vowel in both
backness and in roundness for example
the suffix meaning without which has
four forms so you number says countless
literally without number
information
uninformed or ignorant literally without
information so water
thirsty or dehydrated literally without
water huge power
powerless or weak literally without
power
and if you add additional suffixes the
vowel Harmony continues
ignorance or unawareness thirstiness
powerlessness this suffix here changes
an adjective into an abstract noun
similar to how the vowels of suffixes
change depending on what comes before
them changes take place in some
consonants too this is called consonant
mutation the consonants that can mutate
are called non-continuous consonants the
ones that can't mutate are called
continuous consonants words can't end in
these soft or voiced consonants except
in certain loan words and in a few
single syllable words at the end of a
word they must be their voiceless
equivalents
but if they're followed by a vowel they
go back to being voiced they become
softened we can see this in the
different case forms of the word it
comes from the Arabic word kitab but it
changed to fit the phonology of Istanbul
Turkish
you can still hear the voiced B sound in
the accusative genitive and dative case
forms in which it's followed by a vowel
so this is the rule in the standard
Turkish of turkey in various dialects
though and in closely related turkic
languages like azerbaijani words can end
in a voiced consonant Also let's be
clear that this is for non-continuous
soft consonants the ones that change the
continuous soft consonants can come at
the end of a word and also remember that
the continuous hard consonants never
mutate either
consonant mutation also affects suffixes
that begin with
when a word ends in a hard consonant
meaning a voiceless consonant J becomes
becomes
here's an example erdan from the house
from the tree and again note that the
vowel difference in the two suffixes is
due to vowel Harmony a couple more
examples
Greek meaning the Greek language English
Russian
this is a suffix that creates language
names out of the names of countries
the default word order of Turkish is
s-o-v subject object verb
this sentence means their dad knows
Turkish meaning the Turkish language
notice the sov word order subject object
verb means father or dad while is the
possessive suffix meaning there
is the base form of the verb which means
to know with a present continuous suffix
EOS attached in its third person
singular form we'll talk more about
verbs in a minute
is the noun for the Turkish language the
word for Turkish or turk when not
referring to the languages
Turkish coffee Turk coffee it's in
Translation it seems like an adjective
here but grammatically it's actually a
noun this is a compound noun meaning
something like Turk it's coffee
in compound nouns the second noun has a
possessive suffix to show that it
belongs to the first noun
if we use an actual adjective this
suffix isn't present
hot coffee notice that the adjective
comes before the noun and in the
compound noun the modifying noun comes
first also note that nouns in Turkish
have no grammatical gender so the
adjective doesn't change form for gender
agreement what if we wanted to turn this
into a question it's quite simple
does their dad know Turkish you just add
the yes or no question marker at the end
of the sentence but this word has four
forms depending on vowel Harmony it's
also inflected for person but notice
that there's no suffix in the third
person
let's look more at verbs and how they're
inflected of course they're affected by
agglutination with suffixes that
indicate tense person number and so on
the infinitive form of a verb consists
of the verb's base followed by Mark or
make depending on the last vowel of the
base here are a couple of examples
to sleep each make to drink but other
suffixes can be attached as well
negative verb forms have the suffix ma
or me after the verb base
not to sleep each mimic not to drink
let's conjugate these verbs in the
general present tense known as the ARs
tense take this sentence meaning I sleep
seven hours a day
word for word it's day lucrative case
seven hour I sleep so we have the verb
base which is followed by the arist
suffix the suffix has different forms
when the verb base ends in a consonant
either an I type vowel or an E-Type
vowel
then after the ARs tense a suffix
showing person a personal suffix is
added with no suffix indicating third
person
we drink tea every morning word for word
it's every morning tea we drink again
you can see the verb base followed by
the aorist suffix followed by a personal
suffix now let's look at the present
continuous tense
they're sleeping
the present continuous suffix is eos
which loses its initial vowel when the
verb base ends in a vowel but when the
verb base ends in a consonant the suffix
begins with a vowel with I type vowel
Harmony
then after the present continuous suffix
a personal suffix is added
these personal suffixes can also be
added to nouns and adjectives
functioning with the meaning of subject
plus the copula in particular in the
present tense for example
I'm a doctor or just because the
Standalone subject pronoun can be
dropped
I'm wealthy
means wealthy when the sentence is
negative there's a negative copula e and
the personal suffixes attached to the
end of it
I'm not wealthy
there's also an auxiliary verb imek
which appears in past tense and
conditional suffixes it doesn't appear
in that form you make but as one of
several derived forms which are
conjugated
I was wealthy
here you can see that it's not a
standalone verb but its past tense
endings are suffix to an adjective
the past tense of verbs is also formed
with the same past tense suffixes
I lived in Ankara
notice that the past tense suffix has
eight forms depending on consonant
mutation and vowel Harmony and it takes
one of these personal suffixes
how about the future tense it's formed
by adding the suffix or attack to the
verb is added as a buffer when the verb
base ends in a vowel and vowel Harmony
determines the vowels of the suffix
we will go to the store
is the dative form of the word Maza
meaning store
is the first person plural form of the
verb meaning to go in the future tense
notice that the non-continuous consonant
becomes de because the future suffix
begins with a vowel
now that we've had a look at some of the
important features of Turkish let's look
at some basic phrases and we'll probably
encounter some new features along the
way
hello this comes from Arabic Marhaba
there's also a more informal greeting
which comes from Arabic Salem
how are you
means how and is the personal suffix
meaning you in the singular
I'm fine thank you means good or fine
and IM is the first person singular
suffix in other words I
is a noun meaning
colloquial English a thank you it comes
from Arabic the verbal noun of the verb
meaning to be thankful to someone just
like in English how we don't say thank
but rather thanks with an s in Turkish 2
the plural of the noun is used
the more informal way to say thanks is
but there's also the more formal or
serious expression
it didn't means I do it's the first
person singular present tense form of
it's make literally this is like a thank
you I do
so we could Loosely translate it as I
thank you or I give thanks
another informal way to say thank you is
so this literally means be alive or be
healthy means alive or healthy while all
is the imperative form of the verb Omak
which means to become or to be
is the possessive suffix meaning you're
in the plural but in this case the
formal singular and Ne is a question
word meaning what
to ask this more informally you would
ask
and in response
my name is Hassan but of course change
Hassan to whatever your name is is the
possessive suffix meaning my notice that
in both cases the vowels in the suffix
are in harmony with the unrounded back
vowel in the noun
nice to meet you
is the root of the verb which is used
with the meaning of to meet but
literally means to know each other is
actually a reciprocal suffix
is a form of the suffix which forms
nouns from verbs in this case meeting or
acquaintance here it has ta rather than
due to consonant assimilation with the
Shah consonant that comes before it and
notice that the consonant mutates and
becomes soft when it's followed by a
vowel
is a first person singular possessive
suffix so we can think of this as my
meeting you or my acquaintance with you
and ah is a date of suffix meaning for
so the whole word can be translated as
for my meeting you or for my
acquaintance with you it's a rather
Advanced word to break down if you just
need to know how to say nice to meet you
so beginners might just want to memorize
it
is an adjective meaning pleased or
grateful it comes from Arabic
is the first person singular past tense
form of the verb Omak meaning to become
which we saw a minute ago so this phrase
means I became pleased but as a result
of that change I'm pleased right now
a simpler way to say nice to meet you is
you can skip that first word that was a
little complicated to break down
where's the train station is the word
for train that was borrowed from French
also comes from French station
is the question word meaning where let's
go back to this compound noun for a
minute in a compound noun like this at
the end of the second word there's an
eye type vowel this is the third person
singular possessive suffix meaning it's
so this is like the train it's station
the station belonging to the train but
notice that there's no definite article
in Turkish in other words there's no
word meaning the there isn't exactly an
indefinite article either but the word
meaning one is used like an indefinite
article for example
there's a train station over there there
one train station there is is a word
that shows existence like there is or
there are it's also used to express that
you have something
I have money word for word on me money
there is this is the locative case of
the first person personal pronoun Ben is
the word for money
in Turkish there's no exact equivalent
for the word have
I have money can be expressed in another
way too
word for word money my there is in this
sentence at the end of the noun is the
first person singular possessive suffix
the difference between these two
sentences is that this one means I have
money in general while this one
means I have money on me right now
what if there's an explicit subject the
sentence means my mother has money
you could translate it as my mother's
her money there is
means mother and um is the first person
singular possessive suffix in is the
genitive case ending so this whole word
means my mother's has the third person
singular possessive suffix with s before
it as a buffer because ends in a vowel
so in this sentence there's both a
genitive suffix on the word for mother
and a possessive suffix on the possessed
noun you could translate it as my
mother's her money there is
the negative version of vars is
my mother doesn't have money
what do you think of Turkish after
seeing all of the examples in this video
my impression of Turkish is that at
first it might seem strange for speakers
of English and other Indo-European
languages because of its extensive
agglutination and use of vowel Harmony
but those features of Turkish are very
systematic so once you get used to them
they stop feeling so strange if you're a
native speaker of Turkish what do you
think are some interesting expressions
or idioms in your language let us know
in the comments down below and now it's
time to give a shout out to all of the
langfocus patreon supporters especially
the ones whose names appear on the
screen they are the top tier patreon
supporters so many extra special thanks
go out to them
if you liked this video then also check
out the video I made comparing Turkish
and azerbaijani two languages that are
very closely related I guarantee you'll
find it fascinating